I don't think it's the highest thing
that any human can achieve but I think
it's something that we all strive for by
virtue of our nature whether we want to
or not we can call it run away from pain
and pursue pleasure we can call it a
sense of meaning but all these elements
eventually lead up to happiness we're so
constituted that we pursue happiness
it's no coincidence that the founding
fathers put the pursuit of happiness as
one of the self-evident rights it's part
of our nature
there is certainly place in an important
place for for painful emotions so for
example one of the the trends to day one
of the quick fixes is trying to medicate
away every painful emotion that we or
our children students may have and I
think this hurts individuals I think it
hurts our society as a whole painful
emotions can lead to two important
learning painful emotions can lead to
growth failure can lead to important
learning and growth and and that should
be ought to be usually is part and
parcel of any life and certainly a
successful life in fact there's a lot of
research showing that the most
successful people in the world whether
it's scientists or artists are also the
people who have failed at the most times
it chosen ultimately the happiest people
are actually people who allow themselves
to experience the full gamut of human
emotions not people who suppress or
somehow get rid of painful emotions when
when these arise also painful emotions
at times lead us to to creativity while
there is research showing that we tend
to be more creative when we're in a
positive mood and we turn tend to be a
more passive when in a negative mood and
we can also be highly creative and there
are many examples of highly creative
people who were depressed or anxious and
generally unhappy being human is about
having the the whole range the full
range of emotions
what psychologists have shown is that
material affluence is not correlated
with happiness except for in extreme
cases so if a person's basic needs are
not met food shelter basic education
then that certainly affects their levels
of happiness if someone doesn't have an
individual freedoms under a dictatorship
then that person's happiness will
certainly be influenced so there are
certain things that society can do
mostly by by giving freedom by allowing
people to pursue their happiness now the
Declaration of Independence doesn't say
that we have the right to happiness it
says that we have the right to pursue
happiness and that's a very smart
political as well as psychological
statement